Hello, welcome back to human emotion. Um,
today we'll be returning to a
discussion of morality and emotions.
So what role can emotion actually
play in making us moral creatures?
So how can it influence whether we
behave good or whether we behave bad?
And how much do emotions
actually influence our
decisions of what might be right
from what might be wrong?
And then how much in turn can
influence our own moral behavior?
Can it shape whether we act virtuous
and good or act wrong or bad?
So this is where we're going
to turn to questions such as,
can emotions actually underlie
morally good behavior?
Can emotions actually make us good
people or good citizens of the planet?
By contrast, can emotions also make
us bad as well? So today though,
we're going to focus on the ways in
which emotions may actually make us good.
So this is our second part in
understanding emotion and morality.
So here we're going to
talk about the good side.
So we're going to talk about
feelings of compassion, of elevation,
and of gratitude,
and what way they may actually shape
morally virtuous or good behavior.
So in other words,
this is the lighter side of
emotion and morality particular,
we're going to cover our
roadmap today as follows.
We're going to start with compassion,
turn to gratitude and elevation and
conclude with our takeaway questions and
expert interview.
So let's first start with this emotion
that we've probably all felt but maybe
never thought about. How it might actually
shape our own moral, the good behavior,
which is this emotion of compassion.
And if we were turned to our broader
moral emotion families we saw in our last
lecture,
we'll see that compassion falls in
what's called the two smaller families of
moral emotions outlined by Jonathan Heit.
Now he said that compassion is what's
called an other suffering emotion.
So remember that the core feature of
moral emotions included prosocial or
benevolent action tendencies.
And it was,
we know from discussing earlier in class,
um,
emotions motivate certain kinds
of behavioral action tendencies.
Originally we talked about them in terms
of flying or fighting or fleeing or
fighting. But when we get
to the moral emotions here,
we're going to see action tendencies
that are more intended towards benefiting
other people. And upholding
the social order. So here,
let's start with this other suffering
class of emotions called compassion.
So this is the oldest
class of moral emotions,
originally referred to as sympathy.
And also compassion.
And early scholars wrote about compassion
as the foundation or backbone of human
reality, including Adam Smith. He said,
when we see a stroke aimed and just ready
to fall upon the leg or arm of another
person,
we naturally shrink back and draw
back our own leg or our own arm.
And when it does fall,
we feel it in some measure and are
hurt by it as well as the sufferer.
So as you can see,
an Adam Smith's early observations,
compassion is really defined as being
moved by another suffering or a deep
feeling and understanding of the misery
or suffering and and of another person.
And having this sort of concomitant
desire to try to alleviate suffering in
someone,
to try to help them feel better.
So compassion is really interesting
too because it was also talked about,
um, in early evolutionary theories,
as you can see here by Darwin.
So he thought that compassion,
which he called sympathy,
was associated with natural selection,
survival of the fittest,
and thought that compassion was
actually one of our strongest instincts.
So he argued that it has been increased
through natural selection over time,
and that those communities which
had the greatest number of the most
compassionate or sympathetic people
would flourish best and rear the greatest
number of offspring.
So he said that just hear that sympathy
will have increased through natural
selection for those communities,
which included the greatest member
of the most sympathetic members would
flourish best and rear the
greatest number of offspring.
So not only is compassion seem to be some
of the most central moral backbone of
who we are,
Darwin here even argued that it's what
promoted our longterm survival and was
naturally selected for over
the course of evolution.
So we've been selected to be
compassionate species. He would argue.
So compassion's
interesting because indeed,
as you can see here in all these pictures,
we've seen a variety of humanitarian
crises in recent years such as Hurricane
Katrina or the major earthquake in Haiti.
And compassion doesn't just drive us
to help people who are related to us,
but often drives us to
help complete strangers.
And people we may have never even met.
So for this reason,
when we think of kind of evolutionary
analyses of compassion and pro social
behavior, it can be sort of difficult
or tricky to explain, right?
Because when we act for
the benefit of others,
it's often that a great cost or maybe
even risks to our own selfish wellbeing.
So why will we be born as
these compassionate beings
moved to try to help people
that we don't even know
that live thousands of miles
away to help them at our
own selfish cost of time,
of resources,
of energy as it because we are truly an
innately compassionate human beings that
care about the broader, greater,
greater social order of humanity.
So I think we want to first start
then when we think about how powerful
compassion is and how much it's been
discussed as the central feature of what
makes us human by first taking a
step back and asking ourselves, well,
what is compassion in the first place?
So compassion is defined as follows,
the experience of feelings,
chiefly emotions similar in kind to
those expressed by or known to exist in
another person.
It sets aside our own personality and
moves us to partake of the pleasure or
pain,
the happiness or misery of other people.
Okay.
So when we think about our analysis we've
done with many emotions in this course
and break it up in terms of
an illicit or action tendency,
compassion has really evolved out
of this mammalian attachment system.
And as such,
it is elicited by perceiving distress
or suffering in another individual.
This need not be just our own kin.
It need not even be just humans.
As you can see here. We also may feel
it for other animals such as dogs, um,
and other pets in our lives.
And the action tendency that's really
important is when we proceed this distress
or suffering and other people,
we are motivated to act pro socially to
help them to comfort them or alleviate
their suffering.
So compassion has this really prosocial
orientation to try to remedy the
suffering of others at first sight of it.
Okay?
So we know 'em and work by Daniel Batson.
As you can see here that compassion and
related feelings of empathy really take
us outside of ourselves and
orient us towards other people.
So in Daniel Batson's work,
he asked participants to feel empathy
and or he asked them to just be objective
and found that when people
are asked to feel empathy,
which is related to compassion,
that it actually led to greater concern
for other people and importantly
motivated more helping or pro
social behavioral tendencies.
So it not only turns our
attention outwards but then
motivates us to act in ways
that assist or aid other people.
Okay.
Importantly, compassion is something
that we seem to almost be born with,
right Darwin and say we were naturally
selected or to have the system in us from
very young.
So you see research showing that from
birth to 14 months in infants that they
will react with distress
to cries of other infants,
perhaps showing compassion for distress
of other individuals around their same
age.
And then after the first year of life,
this distress of others can actually
then lead them to engage in helping
behaviors. So they first pick
up on distress and mimic it.
And then later on in life,
even just after one year of age,
this distress that they see admitted and
others actually motivates them to try
to go alleviate suffering and
to help others. So indeed,
it does seem to be that were profoundly
compassionate beings and that this is
something that emerges very,
very early on in life for us.
We also see, uh, compassion
across species. So for example,
one study looked at on a distressed
albino rat who was suspended in mid air as
you can see here on right.
And what they found is that another fellow
rat would actually make the effort to
press the lever to lower
this rat to the ground.
So there's a sense in which they saw
even albino rats who see another distress
rat will be motivated to
engage in behavior to help
that individual and relieve
or alleviate their suffering.
Similarly,
we also see this in nonhuman primates.
So rhesus monkeys will also press
a bar to receive a food reward,
large or small. The large
food reward, however,
causes electric shocks for another monkey.
So upon realizing this,
most monkeys will forego a larger food
reward and stop pressing the bar in order
to alleviate the distress of the,
uh,
electrically shocked McGee.
So they're not only trying to
alleviate the distress of a muggy,
but they'll forgo their own
personal concerns for food. Right?
So it seems that humans and other
species are really built to try to Ha,
you know, be a compassionate and
alleviate the suffering of others.
So we've talked about compassion and
now I want to turn to gratitude and
elevation.
So this is our final four cell box here
where we're going to conclude with this
final,
smaller family of moral emotions,
which are called the other praising moral
emotions like gratitude and elevation,
again,
as outlined by Jonathan Height.
So when we think of
gratitude and elevation,
it seems that they may represent this
sort of brighter side of moral emotions.
So we know that people are sensitive
to good deeds and moral exemplars,
and these immoral emotions,
gratitude and elevation are thought to
be products of good or virtuous acts by
other people. You can see here helping
people, you know, in a soup kitchen,
helping suffering animals and helping
small children in need of aid.
So first that we think about gratitude,
again,
using this kind of functional analysis,
we see that gratitude is elicited by a
perception that another person has done a
good deed for yourself, whether it's
intentional or voluntary, right?
Someone's done something good for you.
This leads you to feel
grateful or gratitude for them.
So it's defined as a state
of being grateful, warm,
and friendly towards some benefactor.
And gratitude is thought to be this
important human strength as well, right?
It contributes to personal wellbeing,
civic engagement,
and even spiritual satisfaction.
Um,
and the action tendency then associated
with gratitude has this what they call
moral motive.
So it makes people act more
pro socially and help others.
So when you feel grateful for
something someone has done to you,
you're more likely than to go and sort
of pay it forward by doing something good
to someone else. So, not surprisingly,
a whole host of psychological
interventions under this broad umbrella of
positive psychology have actually
created and cultivated what they call
gratitude interventions to try to elicit
feelings of daily gratitude and people
in to not only have them appreciate the
benefactors are people that have done
good for them,
but in turn to motivate people to pay it
back and do good deeds towards others.
Okay.
And interestingly,
um,
there's been research showing
that gratitude not only
as good for other people
in terms of promoting pro social behavior,
but gratitude in and of itself
may actually be healthy for us.
So Michael McCullough did a study where
he showed that increased gratitude not
only benefits those
who are the recipients,
but that the more you feel gratitude,
so the more you're feeling
grateful on a daily basis,
it actually enhances your
resilience to stressors.
Your physical health improves as
well as your overall quality of life.
So feeling grateful is it really good for
you? And so, as we touched on earlier,
this has led to a really
prominent and powerful focus.
Um,
some people even call it an explosion of
these gratitude interventions that are
aimed to promote psychological
wellbeing alongside more traditional
psychotherapies such as
cognitive behavioral therapy
or psychodynamic therapy.
These gratitude interventions really seem
to be playing a big role that has yet
been until recently been understudied.
Just the fact that gratitude can
actually promote all kinds of fantastic
physical and emotional
and social benefits.
Yeah.
So when we think about gratitude
and elevation, so again,
this is in this what's called other
praising family. Um, what we saw here,
we just talked about gratitude.
So you know,
the perception that another person has
done a good deed and motivates this kind
of moral motive or more
prosocial action tendency. Um,
but there's also this emotion of
elevation. So this is a really mysterious,
really exciting, um, and really
kind of all inspiring state.
So elevation has also been
called awe, the awe, awe,
and it's experienced,
um,
in response to being around things
that seem larger than the self,
almost this larger than life phenomena.
So you might remember a time
you felt really elevated or awe,
all inspired when you saw
something. Absolutely beautiful. Um,
maybe it was a work of art in a museum.
Maybe you went on a hike in nature and
you are at the top of the mountains
looking out over the world.
Um,
or maybe you saw someone who had just
exceptional actions or abilities.
Um, someone you really revered,
someone you really respected.
And by seeing people who saw or,
or things in the environment
that are really larger than life,
what it motivates you to do is to
become a better person yourself.
To try to take a step up towards being
something that's larger than your current
self.
Okay?
And Jonathan Heit talked
about the state of elevation,
which he recalled as this
manifestation of humanity,
humanity's higher or better nature.
So when people experience elevation,
they report these pleasant
and even almost like tingling,
goosebumps, sensations. Um,
and what it does that's really interesting
is that it turns your attention away
from the self towards becoming a better
person and towards helping other people,
right?
So elevation is this positive emotion
that's elicited when you observe other
people or other parts of your external
world that are particularly virtuous,
commendable, or maybe even
spiritually magnificent in some way.
So it's almost experiencing something
just absolutely amazing and larger than
life itself.
Okay.
Some of these discussions we've had
today about moral emotions and including
discussions of law.
I'm very interested in reading further.
I highly recommend this book by Dacher
Keltner at UC Berkeley called born to be
good.
The science of a meaningful life in which
he talks about all these ways in which
not only are we innately born to be
good people to act compassionately,
to experience elevation and gratitude,
but what are the ways that we
may continue to try to, you know,
leverage our own dispositions to
continue to cultivate a better and more
meaningful life as we continue forward.
Um,
if you're also interested in reading,
um,
Dacher Keltner is also the founder of
the greater good science center at UC
Berkeley.
You can see here,
greater good.berkeley.edu and hear what
you can see as uptodate discussions of
scientific events,
community events that are occurring,
such as you can see here,
different conferences that try to talk
about mindfulness and compassion, um,
as well as a whole host of other
ways to really try to understand and
participate in what they
called the science of a
meaningful and morally virtuous
life. Similarly, at Stanford University,
they've recently founded the
center for compassion and altruism,
research and education.
So it's CC care.stanford.edu if you're
interested in really trying to understand
how can we,
uh,
conduct research to better understand
compassion and altruism and what are
different ways to educate the world, both
students and the general community, um,
to be a more compassionate society.
Okay.
And in closing,
as Jonathan Heit said,
morality is therefore like the temple
on the hill of our human nature.
It is our most sacred attribute,
a trait that is often said to separate
us from other animals and bring us closer
to God. So something's really
special about this lighter,
virtuous side of morality.
It's what makes us human and may actually
help bring us to a more elevated place
and our own existence
here on the planet earth.
Um,
and with that we will turn next week
to talk a little bit about in our third
module on emotion and morality.
What does it look like in
certain individuals who may
lack these fundamentally
virtuous emotions such as
compassion and empathy? Right?
So these emotions are just so critically
important because when we seem to have
an absence of them,
we can see some people performing what
my order considered some of the greatest
evils possible.
So here we can see Ted Bundy,
who many would argue really had
a profound lack of compassion,
empathy when describing some of his
heinous act say, you know, I mean,
there's just so many people.
So we'll have Dr Joshua Buckholtz from
Harvard University speak with us more as
we think about not only the
lighter side of morality,
but what happens when these
morally virtuous emotions
go awry and we delve into
the darker side of morality and emotion.
So with that,
I want to now conclude with our takeaway
questions from our second module on
emotion and morality.
Looking at the lighter or good side.
So the first question asks,
how was compassionate moral emotion?
What are its illicit,
hers and Associated Action Tendencies?
How is gratitude a moral emotion and what
are its illicit bitters and associated
action tendencies?
And similarly for elevation,
how is it in a moral emotion?
And again,
what I really want you to have here as
a sense of how are these emotions truly
moral and what trigger them and what
behavioral tendencies follow from them.
And with that we'll turn to our expert
interview as part of the experts and
emotion interview series.
Today we'll be speaking with doctor Jamil
Zaki on empathy and emotion doctors.
Aki is an assistant professor of
psychology at Stanford University.
His research examines the neural basis
of social cognition and behavior.
In other words,
how do people come to understand each
other and decide to behave towards each
other? So this work spans a
number of domains, including
empathy, theory of mind,
social influence, and pro
social behavior. Doctors, Zach,
he received his BA in
cognitive neuroscience from
Boston University and his phd
in psychology from Columbia University,
after which she conducted postdoctoral
research on altruism and prosocial
behavior at the Harvard
Center for Brain Science.
He's received research and teaching awards
from the Society for personality and
Social Psychology,
the cognitive neuroscience society,
the Society for neuroscience,
the American psychological association,
the association for Psychological Science,
autism speaks as well
as Harvard University.
So I now turn to a very special experts
in emotion interview with one of the
most, uh, empathic people that I know,
which is doctor Jamil Zaki speaking
with us on empathy and emotion.